this we have some companies that we have
put cash in we have companies that we
have in pokasha and the big thing is
like what problem are we solving and so
I would say the vast majority of the
companies that we are working with are
internet-based companies they are
growing they're profitable they have
cash flow and for most of them they
don't need the cash they need the
expertise so for the majority of the
situations it ends up just being cool
we'll take a meaningful enough stake
that that we care but not so much so
that you stop caring so it's really
trying to strike that balance we have
incentives for us to try and like triple
the company within five years and that's
like our big goal that we drive towards
but because we're minority Partners it's
basically like everything kicks in after
we triple that's kind of like what we
drive towards uh with those companies
but most the founders that we're dealing
with or that are approaching us are like
I really want to take this thing to the
next level they're 100 motivated to do
it and they just want more help to get
there faster make fewer mistakes